LA Unified School District as well as
San Diego announced that they're going
to enter into the fall school season the
way they ended last school year and that
is by utilizing distance learning I want
to just acknowledge and applaud the
leadership of those districts
that's California's Democratic governor
Gavin Newsom praising his state's two
largest school districts Los Angeles in
San Diego and that prey is coming after
they announced they will begin the
school year online as coronavirus cases
have spiked again in the Golden State
the decision is affecting more than
eight hundred thousand students and it
comes as other states take different
paths to classes resuming with some
planning hybrid options so some parts at
home some parts digital learning and
they'll do a mix during the week at some
places but the conservative-leaning
Orange County Board of Education voted
yesterday to reopen schools in time for
fall classes for in-person learning and
it says it will not require social
distancing or wearing a mask they say
quote among our greatest
responsibilities as adults is our
responsibility to model courage and
persistence in the face of uncertainty
and fear which is what many families are
feeling with the mixed messages and
confusion surrounding reopening schools
in the Cova 19 era joining me now
White House press secretary Kaley
McInerney Kaylee great to have you on
the programming today good you know I
want to start there because some of the
the concern is that the science speaks
for itself and we're learning a lot we
even saw the president in a mask over
the weekend so we're learning a lot as
we move forward some people were ahead
some people are catching up whatever the
picture looks like in a school setting
it isn't just about the kids it's about
those older educators too and those kids
going home to their grandparents
particularly in communities of color
because you know you're not hiring a
nanny you're depending on your aunts and
uncles and grandparents and maybe
spreading it to them so the kids may not
get sick but we don't know enough dr.
Burke says we're not testing enough of
them to know if they are asymptomatic
years under the age of ten we just
aren't so let me point out a few things
Harris won the president's been clear
that he says vulnerable populations
among our teacher should stay home
that being said dr. Redfield has said on
the record he's the head of the CDC that
this has little effect on kids I'm an
analysis that many an academic community
agree with and he has said not only that
but they're not driving the transmission
cycle there was a study of schools in
northern France that found that despite
Cova Don being in three schools there
was no transmission cycle that was
driven the schools were able to safely
reopen even in this kovat era and we
know that in California alone there has
not been a single death under the age of
18 so kids are not affected in the same
way of as the vulnerable populations
which should stay home in those areas
and I hear you about France they don't
have the number certainly not eight
hundred and twenty five thousand kids in
a school district or across to school
districts but I hear you about
particularly putting these kids in peril
the numbers don't support that they
would be necessarily the carrying part
we can agree to disagree on until
there's more science but who was the
president talking to and listening to in
terms of parents because I want to pop
this up 71% of us parents polled in the
new Axios Epps's coronavirus index say
it would be risky to send children back
to school in the fall including nine in
ten black Americans and even a slim
majority of Republicans that polling
particularly pops when you again
consider that in those areas that's
where Cove in nineteen has decimated so
many people among all ages well first
let me note on the Axios poll we don't
agree with the way that question was
phrased it was phrased in a way that it
seemed to try to get to an answer rather
than truly and accurately pull the
nation I think parents across the nation
understand the science the data and the
numbers which is one-fifth of child
abuse cases are identified in schools
we've seen a 62 percent decrease in
reporting on child abuse here in DC they
know that seventy to eighty percent of
kids with mental problems get their
treatment in schools and they know that
as Mackenzie and Co modeled that
low-income
communities are hurt the most you have 7
and 10 Latinos and about 7 and 10 black
Americans saying they are worried that
they do not have the skills or the
resources I should say at home to to
prep their students and keep them up to
par educationally and that is a real
fear many have and it's a correct fear
all right real quickly is the president
gonna rip funding for schools that feel
like they're in areas where the cases
are spiking and they can't reopen the
president has always acknowledged that
this is something that he'll take a look
at because he believes it's paramount
for kids to go to school but he has also
said he wants that funding to follow the
student and in fact I I'll note for you
here Harrison phase four we're fighting
for tens of billions and extra funding
for our students so we want to increase
it but we want to target it at the
student pays for the grade if Congress
would get back to work then right oh I
said the quiet part out loud Hillary
Clinton once again raising the alarm
about the November election with this
warning about President Trump if he
loses reelection watch this and then
I'll get your reaction Kaley I think it
is a fair point to raise as to whether
or not if he loses he's going to go
quietly or not and we have to be ready
for that
not just Hillary Clinton though Joe
Biden also raised the same possibility
last month when he suggested the
military might have to escort President
Trump from the White House when I sat
down with him the president said if he
loses he'll deal with it the way that
everybody else does basically
paraphrasing him now what's the latest
reaction from the White House on this
well it's quite comical to watch the
Democrat Party talk about not accepting
the results of the election because the
only people who haven't accepted the
results of elections are people in the
Democrat Party like Hillary Clinton
who's blamed her loss someone he was
something like two dozen different
entities never blaming herself and
Stacey Abrams down in Georgia who still
maintains she didn't lose the election
of course she's the losing former
Democrat nominee for governor so the
Democrats have problems with this I
think this is their way of acknowledging
they think they have some real problems
in November all right Kaylee thank you
for being on the probe
I look forward to next time any time
Thank You Harris